Let's just review what we've defined in terms of our API.
We have a function match and a function search,
and they both take a pattern and a text,
and they both return a string representing the earliest longest match.
But for match the string would only return if it's at the start of the string.
For search, it'll be anywhere within the string.
If they don't match, then they return none.
We've also defined an API of functions to create patterns--
a literal string, an alternative between two patterns x and y,
a sequence of two patterns x and y, and so on.
That's sort of the API that we expect the programmer to program to.
You create a pattern on this side and then you use a pattern over here
against a text to get some result.
Then below the line of the API--sort of an internal function--we've defined matchset,
which is not really designed for the programmer to call it.
It was designed for the programmer to go through this interface, but this function is there.
It also takes a pattern and a text.
Instead of returning a single string, which is a match, it returns a set of strings, which are remainders.
For any remainder we have the constraint that the match plus the remainder
equals the original text.
Here I've written versions of search and match. We already wrote matchset.
The one part that we missed out was this component that pulls out the x, y and op components out of a tuple.
I've left out two pieces of code here that I want you to fill in.